Senator great to have you my
friend everyone said before the show
that if you were in their state they'd
all vote for you right they all so you
got a lot of fans well God bless the
great Americans in your audience they
they're fighting to save America listen
they're almost like Texans they're the
only normal people in New York so um
well come down buy a ranch get a horse
live life in Freedom and a new pair of
cowboy boots and a hat and I'm ready to
go uh great to have amen let's get your
thoughts o overall on what we see
unfolding here and what needs to be done
and what role the US should play here
well what is unfolding in Israel is
utterly horrific this is the most
serious attack facing the state of
Israel in 50 years this is Saturday
October 7th was the single biggest mass
murder in a day of Jews since the
Holocaust we have seen Palestinian
terrorists committing horrific acts of
murder going from home to home targeting
civilians murdering the elderly
murdering women murdering children
deliberately executing every member of a
family raping women raping little girls
burning and beheading infants it is evil
there is no moral equivalence everyone
in the media every Democrat who is
saying Hamas and Israel are the same
they're not remotely the same and and it
is critical right now that we stand
together that every American says
America stands with Israel 100% period
full stop for as long as it takes to
utterly and completely defeat Hamas uh
that's what it's going to
take I know you've been to Israel many
times I've been there I was during there
during a flare up and I've been to
border towns with Gaza and I've seen the
Carnage kids in in a serot is what they
call a little small town uh 10,000
Rockets were fired into that one little
city in 10 years
little children because it only takes 13
seconds for a rocket fired in Gaza to
hit this this watering town and so the
kids have to play in underground uh
playgrounds that are bunkers they can't
play outside they don't get vitamin D
very NE you know necessary for good
health right um I don't think people
realize that any outcome doesn't it have
to end any possible opportunity for uh
for the terrorists in Gaza to be firing
there having a launching pad from there
look absolutely yes you and I both know
prime minister Netanyahu very well he is
pledge to eradicate Hamas that is the
right thing and there are three things
that are critical for us to do number
one we need to cut off the money to Iran
the Biden Administration has flowed
nearly $1 100 billion dollar to Iran Joe
Biden his administration is in a very
real sense funding this attack we need
to cut it all off we need to cut the six
billion off that was a ransom for
American hostages that basically set a
bounty for Iran to go take more American
hostages they said they had a secret
deal how do you have a secret deal that
you trust if it's not ratified by the
Senate well look they've been engaged in
secret deals from the beginning Biden's
number one foreign policy priority was
to enter into another Iran nuclear deal
but their answer is funnel billions of
dollars into Iran the Ayatollah is a
Theocratic cdal genocidal Maniac who
leads mobs en chanting death to America
and death to Israel and if you look at
the four pots of money that have gone to
Hamas you've got the 6 billion to Iran
you've got three weeks before that 10
billion to Iran again from the bid
Administration the biggest pot is $80
billion because Biden will not enforce
the oil sanctions so Joe Biden and the
Democrats are allowing Iran today to
sell 2 million Barrel of oil a day
primarily to communist China that is
funding these Hamas terrorists and then
the fourth pot of money is the Biden
Administration sent hundreds of millions
of dollars into Gaza after the Biden
administration had concluded there was a
high likelihood that money would go to
Hamas to fund terrorism against Israel
we need to cut off all that money no
money for Gaza no money for Iran shut
off their oil sales starve them of cash
that's step number one step number two
we need to fund Israel's defensive
Weaponry the Iron Dome missile defense
give them the weapons they need and then
step number three Israel is going to be
demonized by democrats and the cor
corrupt corporate media we need to make
clear that Hamas is using human Shields
and Israel has a right to defend itself
we need to stand up and speak the truth
I'm doing that every week on my podcast
verdict with Ted Cruz you're doing that
thank you Sean for speaking the truth
thank you Senator Ted Cruz for what
you're doing and having more clarity hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else